à quelle heure 20h05
je l'aï entendu julien le stagiaire vous
voulez voir mais j'ai pas voulu
c'était plus d'une heure après la pause
et coups spéciaux ne pouvez pas savoir
ne pas ouvrir une heure après la
fermeture c'est normal vous avez vu son
visage sur l'écran de parlophone on
était dans l' annexe du cabinet on voit
sortir un garçon avec trouver l'eau
c'est votre stage heures oui on va vous
montrer les images si vous la
connaissiez ça peut nous aider beaucoup
parce qu'on n'a rien trouvé sur elle ni
papier ni gsm mais on va voir les images
sur l'ordinateur nos collègues savaient
dès qu elle est morte une fracture
ouverte au crâne mais on ne sait pas si
elle est tombée sur le béton de la berge
ou si on lit à pousser et les traces de
coups l'autopsié externe n'a rien révélé